Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
The doctor is in!
Oh my gosh, I'm so zoomed in.
Give me a sec.
Doctor's very close right now.
Let me fix that real quick.
Whoa, doctors, there's no personal space right now.
I fixed it.
All right, the doctor is back in in doctor needed to go to a
PR training about personal space oh man all right let me
today we're gonna be playing animal hospital is a roblox
game apparently it's uh very popular right now in the roblox
sphere not just for kids roblox not just for kids guys
apparently as a million plus plays people playing, I, okay,
I'm sorry, I saw one person playing, it was chibi-doki, I
thought it was really interesting, and it was like, and I
realized, it was in my Twitter algorithm where, like, a lot
of people were drawing fatter and talking about it too, um,
so you can tell it's not just for kids, guys, my Twitter
algorithm is not just for kids, um, and it's basically, uh,
basically it's like paper pleat, like, it's just like, try,
paper, please, but you're at a hospital, ghosts and also try
to cure the patient it's like everything um so it's like a
semi-hork but i mean it's like it's not it's like a it's a
horror game in a roblox game like how horror can that be you
know like it's horror but you're on roblox so it's like 80s
first horror i guess um it didn't seem that scary uh but
there are ghosts in this game whoa well they were super chat
they could Thank you.
I went to the vet with my dog, and Doki is a doctor.
Chat is my dog.
They give us super chat.
Don't worry.
I got my license on eBay.
All right, there are some actual scary horror Roblox games,
though, but I don't think this is one of them.
They're like cute little animal doctors and nurses and
patients.
I don't remember how to do this.
All right.
Guess this.
This should be the game.
There we go.
That's the game.
All right.
Sound guy.
Are you alive?
Hello.
I'm opening up the basement door.
Sound guy.
Get up.
It's time.
It's time for your daily sound balancing.
It's already alive.
All right.
So next update.
What's this?
Classes.
Oh, yeah.
So I can meet.
Look, I'm so happy.
So I have sanity meters.
So I'm going to be working at the intern still in still in
doctor school oh there's there's a paramedic there's a lot
of yo he's seen things for sure the firefighter why would
the firefighter be at the security oh i get so much money
though sergeant secret agent i start with a gun what the am
i gonna do with a gun i can't just shoot the ghost i could
buy it right now i do i could just buy it i could just Okay,
we'll start with...
We'll do the intern first.
We'll be...
So you can see...
See, there's the spooky doctor already over there.
I did a private server.
Apparently, private servers are free.
Thank God.
Sure you can.
Where are my abuse goons?
Where are they?
Oh, you're still asleep?
Wake up!
It's sound balancing time.
Oh, you guys like my skin?
Thomas the tank engine.
That's me.
It looks just like me.
Ding, ding, ding.
Oh, they're asleep.
All right.
Mons, congratulations.
You've been demoted.
Congratulations.
You've been, you've been demoted.
Mons, time to get in the cage.
Get in a cage and tell me how the sounds like.
All right, I was going to talk about something.
I forgot what it was about.
What was I talking about before?
I'm trying to dig through my brain right now.
I'm a mom, mom, mom, mom, mom, mom, mom.
But there's like different...
I mean, in turn.
I'm a new face.
Haven't seen actual death yet.
Haven't had to tell the family.
Sorry, we couldn't save your kid.
Yeah, it's so like I was happy I am.
Look at that.
I haven't told their family that their child has cancer.
I'm so happy right now.
First day at work.
Depression has yet to set in.
So enthusiastic.
So innocent.
So pure.
Lives haven't been...
Lives not saved.
yet?
That's date.
That's true.
Not day two.
Not yet.
Cat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, bring a snack for the dirty terms.
Oh yeah, my little fish snack.
I'm gonna run around.
Thank you.
Thank you for the fish.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, first day of med school.
Let's go.
So it's like work at the hospital until you find really
happening no shit there's something else happening that's
not like patients dying in my hospital oh can I adjust the
sensitivity let me adjust the sensitivity real quick uh oh
I'm already I don't think I can go lower than that all right
shift one use the camera oh yeah sorry they they we're gonna
detect anomalies all right we're gonna take a picture hello
My name is Noah Yoshida.
Hey Noah.
I'm here for my appointment.
Oh, you have an appointment.
Alright.
Let's take a photo.
What?
Oh, let's look at this.
Oh, take a photo.
Oh, oh, you're real.
Alright.
You're real.
I got your print badge.
It's a lot faster than the real.
You can tell this is a video game because it's a lot faster
getting your appointment.
You actually get to go to your appointment within five to
ten minutes.
I'll be in room one.
Alright.
So you can tell this is a video game.
It's not very immersive.
Not gonna lie.
Alright.
Okay.
Follow a patient to their room.
Alright.
Room number one.
Oh, that's like the how I have to heal them.
Alright.
Take your DNA sample.
Don't worry.
I analyze sample.
The doctor's in.
See, I'm a very good doctor.
Our hospital's a little underfunded right now.
So I'm the doctor, nurse, receptionist.
Oh, minus 1% job stress.
Forensics.
I do it all.
We're very, very underfunded.
I should have went to a private hospital.
Oh, analyze.
Oh, you have a stomach ache?
What can I do about that?
is your stomach okay pat pat pat oh herbs all right uh all
right all right here here comes the airplane like in my
roblox game all right patient is recovering don't are you
feeling better is your stomach getting better now if i jump
on your stomach i'll the the thing that's aching your
stomach thank you doctor oh whoops bandage on head camp not
me yeah yeah I'm just pushing the thing I'm pushing the
thing that's aching his stomach out of his of his stomach
all right all right taking a picture?
Are you real?
You're real!
I'm gonna print your badge.
Ma'am, you're not dying or anything.
You'll be fine.
Thanks.
I will be in room two.
Okay.
Oh, I got chocolate.
Is my sad?
Oh, I got... Oh, I have to buy a gun.
How much is it?
Oh, $99.
Okay.
Are the myths real?
What myths?
all right we trust our professional that's me i'm
professional all right got your dna sample don't worry ma'am
i'll fix you
all right dried eyes you went to the hospital for that you
could oh my god just go to a pharmacy all right anyway i
mean you know what fine that'll be 50 000 The doctor is
arriving.
I thought I was the doctor.
Down very, very slightly.
No problem.
All right, give me a sec.
I don't know if I...
I don't think I can pause this game.
Because it's on...
I can't pause the video game, mom.
It doesn't work like that.
Oh, I'm Dr. Harlow.
Oh, wait.
I forgot I was the intern.
You must be the new...
Yeah, that's me.
If things get strange, just keep working.
shutters and security cameras for you oh you're doctor and a
mechanic oh oh okay you shutters to reject people don't
worry it's a healing gun all right oh i did a good job i
patient treated yeah how do i do this oh my god best that's
me i'm best oh oh he has very, very dried eyes.
Hey.
I'm here for my appointment.
Guys, you can't judge a book by its cover.
Guys, we can't judge a book.
Okay, we're going to judge a book by its cover.
We're going to judge a book by its cover.
Goodbye.
I think we cat it's true i he could have been on a lot of
drugs you don't know that just because he looks fucked up
doesn't mean he's an anomaly what's the point of like of it
i've heard did not look all right let's see you okay all
right you seem fine can you treat him for possession Not
today, Satan.
Alright, room one.
He could have had really, really dried eyes.
Exactly!
I mean...
I'll take this guy in for now.
I'm Nina Hopp.
Also, sound guy.
I've lowered the volume.
Oh.
I mean...
Guys, he could be having had a lot of coffee.
see he's fine look at that they hate photos look at that see
this guy this guy is just he's just he's just on a lot of
coffee guys wait what room was the other guy in room one oh
huh should be fine oh oh okay that's what i just don't look
at it just don't having new interior.
We have a new interior decorator.
Do not worry.
Just don't look up.
Close your eyes.
Headache.
And he's Canadian.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
You're here for American healthcare.
Okay.
And maple syrup.
All right.
It's okay.
I know.
I'm sorry.
That'll be $60,000.
At least you're getting the...
At least you're getting the care faster.
You have to wait five to six business years.
Okay, as long as I don't stand there.
Okay.
It's okay.
You might have...
Look, this hospital is very, very crowded right now.
We might take it...
We're very, very occupied.
Very, very...
Big vac...
No vacancy right now.
So y'all share...
Y'all share bunks with this guy.
Bruises.
Alright, Medkit.
He's just a supervisor.
Like, I'm sorry.
You gotta share and have a bunkmate.
Look, our hospital is very severely underfunded.
Hello.
Do you, though?
Do you, you're dying.
This is the only place you can go.
Alright.
Look.
Look, people have to share bunk beds now, guys.
I'll be in room five.
All right, room five.
Yeah, he's an emotional support ghost.
All right, let's go.
Hurry up.
How am I supposed to heal you faster if you don't hurry up?
Come on.
Hurry up.
Time is money.
I got charged you $70,000 for this bedroom.
all right all right analyze sample what do we have here what
kind of illness do you have how fucked up are you wait I
actually need it all right just a little tummy ache don't
worry I got you herb
he's still underneath the oh hey oh You have the funds for
to stay in the hospital.
You know how, like, um, um, you know how they charge you
for, like, even if you're giving birth or whatever, they
charge you, like, 70 grand or some shit.
Oh!
What do I do about that?
Do I just...
Oh, I had...
Oh, okay, well...
Hey!
Do you have a license to start a ritual in this room?
You didn't pay for this.
Alright.
Hey, you need a...
You didn't pay.
Make an appointment.
You want to start a ritual.
Illegal ritual.
Alright.
It cost you extra.
Yeah, your insurance did not approve of this.
Oh, my sanity is a little...
Oh, a little coffee.
I don't know why.
I'll drink a little coffee later.
I'm opening new facilities for you.
All right.
What do I have?
The supply shop will be open for a limited time each shift.
All right, what do I get from there?
What's the word for when the hospital gets overcrowded?
There's a word for it.
Nice.
I prevented one and I know what he died.
Let's go.
No one died or have 104 refresh Extra check-in recovery
sanity over brief period It's just overcrowded like when we
like Amid it too many people You know it's like airlines
where they oh that's that's a bat That's that oh that guy
guys eyes very very dry You know how like airlines they
would overbook Oh Um Oh!
What?
Hello?
Um...
Overcapacity?
Double booked?
Is that it?
Um...
Uh...
Give them... Do I shoot it?
Well, I don't... I know you're... I know you're... Oh, it's
you!
What the fuck do I...
do sir sir sir you need to sir you need to sir sir please
you need to leave oh
all right sorry we can't no service no no no service sorry
we're close lunch break lunch break right now all right okay
you see okay now i do need to drink some coffee give me a
sec all right just just a little bit of coffee all right
sorry i'm on my 16 hour shift right now we have it was
strict no demons policy hospital is three blocks away.
Sorry, but you're in the wrong hospital.
Visitors fainted.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Sorry.
Maybe I should have made him wait 18 hours for his room for
his appointment.
All right.
Get in here.
Oh, you got the fancy bed just because you fainted.
How do I check you up?
Oh, IV.
All right.
Is that everything?
Okay, now I gotta check up on you.
Code blue, code blue!
Is that how it does?
Do you do it?
You faint so you can get the fancier hospital bed?
Oh, shit.
It's time to play...
Oh, shit!
Oh, boy!
Do I click on the red scop?
What was that tapping rhythm game called?
It's time to play Osu, guys.
I'm Ozu-ing.
Should be fine.
Alright.
Heart scan complete.
Oh, what do you have?
You are...
Oh, you're a fever.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I need...
This.
Oh, my God.
Code red.
You have a fever.
Don't worry.
A thermometer will fix everything.
Don't wash your hands.
Good advice.
Okay, where is it?
Alright, here.
Oh, he has evil eyes.
It couldn't be that evil.
Yeah, see, look.
He's okay.
It's just the way he was born.
Don't judge a book by its cover.
He was just born that way.
What do I even use this for?
Like, I don't know what to do with the camera.
He was just born A threat to society With the way he
discovered Barney's first Encounter?
Who's Barney?
Who the fuck is Barney?
Oh Camera show anomalies?
Oh!
He just Has cataracts.
Exactly!
Alright, what's wrong with you?
Yeah Low sugar.
Okay, maple syrup.
Thank God we have maple syrup.
Alright, that's the reason why your eyes are so black.
Alright, go recover.
Aleparnian?
Did I?
I can drink more coffee.
I should just drink this.
Alright.
What's that sound?
Okay.
Nothing bad.
Oh, you want...
Oh!
God.
Give me 161 seconds.
You can wait that long, right?
Uh, that's awkward.
Uh, sorry, Barney.
Are you Barney?
Oh.
Oh, I'm not paying 19 robux.
What the fuck?
You gotta wait like everyone else, Barney.
Hey, room one?
Does room one have coffee?
That's gloves.
Where's the coffee around here?
Did any nurses or doctors left their coffee?
I mean, I don't think I'm timed or anything, so it should be
fine.
I'm not losing sanity.
We're just chilling.
You better watch out.
I don't.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, wait.
Party.
Wait, no.
Don't party.
Oh, no.
He does not like it.
I couldn't do.
I'm sorry.
I already drank my coffee.
Oh, well.
me there's no way that'll bite me in the ass later right
there's no way he's going to the press joe yamada i want to
check in as a patient all right give me your form
you should be fine you look normal all right here you go all
right let's go room two Let's go.
There are stories about this place.
Oh my god, what's wrong with your head?
Oh wait, that's just how you were born.
Alright.
Go do your thing.
Folk.
And then...
What is wrong with you right now?
Little man?
Why did you come to your hospital?
Instead of going to...
Bleeding, fluent, rash.
shit okay bandages cough syrup and ointment okay i can get
all that bandages cough syrup and which one's ointment
ointment there you go i didn't do it i don't think i don't
know about to do it i'll do an order just in case there you
go you're all better now that'll be 100 grand i heard you
don't have insurance too that'll be 150 grand all right you
just seem very tired oh there you He's just depressed, guys.
It's okay.
It's okay, everybody.
He's just depressed.
All right.
That'll be in room seven.
Order doesn't matter, thank God.
Don't worry.
What?
Oh, my God.
Not again.
Sir!
You didn't book in a...
You did not add starting ritual in this for your
appointment, sir.
Sir!
Your past visiting hours are over!
Oh my god!
Sir, visiting hours are over!
You can only... Oh, look at you!
You're so tiny!
Look at you!
Look at this tiny little guy!
We serve everybody.
Even rats!
Yeah, definitely need a little coffee.
What?
Did you hear that?
Did you guys Treat remaining Wonder, Warren, Did you guys
hear the little The pitter-patter?
Okay, you're fine.
Alright, it's the O-Suitab.
Okay, it's IV.
Alright, O-Suitab.
Oh, wow, that's close.
Almost got me.
there okay you're gonna be an actor you can actually like
click it away like from it all right done new record oh what
and what do i need to close the blinds a little worries me a
little bit i have to close it okay low sugar headache
bruises maple syrup medicine medkit all right maple syrup
medkit ointment all right here we go say oh wait it's whoops
medicine don't worry let me oh fuck that went to get the
ointment did you say ointment another ointment let me rub
the let me rub the fever away Okay, number four.
I gotta be sure there's nothing crazy here.
And a sample.
You want me to put more lotion on your open wound?
Is that what you want?
First day of the job.
I think I'm doing great.
Bleeding.
Okay, bandages.
That's fine.
All right.
Then you put a bandage on your head.
Should be better now.
Yay!
Doctor, doctor!
I did a great job!
What does a doctor even do?
Now I'm wondering what the doctor does in his hospital.
I feel like he just shows up and builds me more shit.
They seem unstable.
What do I do?
I have a gun.
And stay alert.
Okay.
I'll unlock the taser.
Use it wisely?
Where's the taser?
Oh, shit.
Shock suspicious people?
Alright, I prevented one anomaly.
Oh, the shop's open.
Time to shop.
Oh, I can buy a gun.
Shoot people.
Alright, faster printer.
I have enough for that.
I'll grab a faster printer.
Bucket.
Out of employment.
Oop.
Take a picture.
Are you normal?
Nice.
More money.
Alright, here you go.
What room are you going to?
I'll be in room 7.
Okay.
Is there anybody freaky around?
Oh, wait.
The camera's down.
That's a little freaky.
Why is the camera down?
Hello.
Oh, you're back.
Did you hurt yourself again?
You're a good guy.
I am a good guy.
My paychecks are coming in.
My name is Rathu.
My advice?
Don't trust anyone here.
Oh, that's a little suspicious.
But I should drink more coffee, though.
Why is there pitter-patter?
All right, everything's fine.
all right boop seemed like a good guy he's not scared of the
camera all right now I'll be in room four okay we gotta
start healing people all right room four oh that's not him
wait where's the other guy oh that that's that seems like a
bad guy all right what's wrong with you Oh, sue time.
Eh.
Okay, how the fuck am I supposed to press that?
Alright.
Apparently it's a four-player game, too.
I assume, like, one would be the receptionist and the others
would, like, tend to the people.
I feel like I should play this solo first before I invite
you guys in.
Oh, shit!
Okay, it's okay.
He's not dead.
He has three lives.
It's like a cat.
Heart scan complete?
Alright, what's wrong with you?
Okay, bleeding.
Okay, you just need bandages.
Yeah, they're fine.
Alright.
Boop.
I don't think I need to give you this room for bandages, but
that's okay.
Alright, what's taking so long?
Yeah, I don't trust you.
Get out of here!
Damn right I am!
I discriminate!
That's right.
I profiled you.
See, I was too trusting at first.
And from that experience, I started profiling.
Damn.
Whoa.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
Time!
I can finally use the ointment!
Thermal and maple syrup.
Okay.
And maple syrup.
That's right!
You haunted me once!
Now I don't trust anyone with no eyes.
You have no eyes?
You must be a demon!
Alright.
You okay?
You're okay.
got room five oh shit oh shit don't go into room five
I don't oh don't go into room five I don't go into room
five I'm trying
oh shit okay give me let me grab society first before I do
anything let me I Oh my gosh, I do too!
Look for the fires.
What do I do?
I was trained to be a firefighter.
I...
Okay.
All I have is a taser.
Surely that guy won't die, right?
Oh my god.
about the hell he'll be fine
okay it's all right it's okay it's all right you said we
were testing out a new a new heater it's a bit hot in there
why are you checking it on a patient the room is on fire
guys i need to pay off the fire extinguisher guys all right
there you go i need to make money i need earn money to make
money oops okay if only you bought the gun hello oh hey
there it seemed like a very important person i'm gonna
charge you triple space thank you in the super chat thank
you Thank you.
Oh, it's Ron from accounting.
Okay, room 8.
What's that above?
Oh, shit!
Is that surgery?
Okay.
Alright.
Begin surgery.
Oh, God.
My first day is my first day on the job.
I thought I was, oh my god, scalpel, scalpel Okay, scissors
Bandage, bandage, IV Oh, thank god, successful Open heart
surgery, let's go You know, I thought when I went to med
school I went for like general What's this?
Copy the sequence?
Red, yellow blue, pink, red, yellow, blue, pink.
Oh, I didn't rise.
I just kept going.
Red, yellow, blue, pink.
Oh, shit.
Okay, you go get scammed.
Did you see it?
Pat your ass and then you were super chapped.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, no.
Get out of here.
Yeah, no.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Here we go.
What's wrong with you?
You just need a bandage?
Ointment.
Medkit.
Okay, Ointment, Medkit.
Ointment.
Alright.
Don't worry, Ryan.
I got you.
You're off to do more accounting now.
Alright.
Look, you should be lucky that you're even waiting, like,
five minutes for an appointment.
This could have been a five-hour thing.
Oh, if I tase an anomaly, I can get my...
Oh, I should start...
Tase and ask questions later.
What?
Who started this fire?
We didn't start the fire.
Bada-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Bada-na-na-na.
We're just getting the room sorted out for you, ma'am.
Don't worry.
Let me put this back here to recharge it.
All right, you seem fine.
Yeah, I went to med school for, like, boat, like, we're,
like, you know, general medical stuff, not for open heart.
That was, that's not my specialization.
know we are a bit underfunded so i guess i'll learn open
heart surgery on the job you know maybe i'll just i could
just watch up a tutorial video right i'll just i watch i
watch a tutorial on youtube to figure it out
all right yeah i'm like i'm like a gynecologist and they're
like time to do open heart surgery it's almost the same wait
a minute
all right nice all right number five i'm gonna name i'm just
gonna call you by numbers so i don't have a personal
attachment to you if you happen to die it'll just be number
five to me all right leading bruce is canadian bandages
medkit and maple syrup i don't even have to look at it
bandages medkit all right here we go
There you go.
My condolences.
Your free healthcare does not apply here.
We're in America.
Doctors arriving.
Hey there.
There's been a huge anomaly attack!
Six people died many more.
Oh, shit!
Not here, right?
Be prepared.
The ambulance is...
Oh, no!
Oh, my God.
We should move!
Oh, shit.
He's freaking out.
Oh, I can fix this camera.
Wait, why are you stressed?
You're the doctor!
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
And...
Oh, oh.
Visitor Fainted?
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Room 7.
Alright.
Okay, I need to go to room 7.
Set!
Five.
six, seven.
Oh, no, no, not...
Oh, we're double-booked right now.
We're fully occupied.
Oh, the IV!
Don't look up!
Okay.
We're gonna save you!
But if I don't...
Sorry.
You signed a contract.
It's in their terms of conditions.
If you happen to die, it's not the hospital's
responsibility.
You see, no hospital is 100%.
That's just impossible.
Oh.
Oh, don't look up.
Bandages.
Medicine.
Wait a minute.
Bandages.
Ointment.
Medicine.
Don't worry.
I got you.
There you go.
all right oh there's a lot of people that's sick right now
okay copy a sequence don't look up green blue green blue
like green blue it's gonna live don't look up don't look up
just a friendly neighborhood drooler look because this
hospital is so severely underfunded okay bandages maple
syrup medicine we're also an airbnb on the side okay all
right nice all right next room number eight Oh, shit.
Okay.
Look, we're also, like, a partial BNB as well.
To...
Oh, shit.
Where's the...
Bandage.
Oh, what's that sound?
Hope it's nothing too bad.
Oh!
Oh,
it's fine.
They were anomaly.
Okay.
It's okay.
They were anomalies.
Technically, I didn't kill anyone.
Oh.
Get off!
Get off of him!
Visiting hours are over!
Oh, and there's a fire!
Oh my god, all right.
All right, give me a sec.
Oh, no.
What was I supposed to know?
That was an anomaly.
All right.
I'm suing the hospital.
Hey, hey.
In the fine print, the hospital said it will not take any
anomalies.
So it's not my fault.
You went to the wrong hospital.
Medkit and ointment.
All right.
Where's the ointment?
It's not my- these treatments are for non-anomalies only.
It is not my fault that the treatment did not work with you.
Like how was I supposed to know your anomaly if you're
pretending to be real?
Alright, here we go.
Alright, what do I need?
eyedrops medkit all right that's fine eyedrops medkit all
right nice you'll be fine now all right doctor did i do a
good job i think i did a great job okay i need the coffee
too all right let's grab this taser just in case good job
the see is over for now.
Yay!
My more amulets will come.
Come.
Be prepared.
Alright.
Can't be too bad.
I think I did a really good job.
Oh, here's a...
Look at... I got a bonus.
I got a bonus, guys.
For a job well done.
Alright.
10.
0 2.
0 deaths!
Look at that.
And a hundred... Oh my god.
And I got a Christmas bonus.
I'll grab a faster PC Look at that And I get a Christmas
bonus On top of it Alright Picture You real?
You're real Those anomalies will be very disappointed They
couldn't read Hey this is a non-anomaly hospital We don't
serve anomalies here we're not profiling or anything we just
don't have the we're just our hospice just not built for it
we just don't have the medicine to treat you we don't have
the expertise the
specialization it's not racist we just don't have the care
you need oh what the fuck how do I get
goop i guess i'll just walk to the side oh you're not this
one you're room number one he'll be fine right yeah it'll be
fine i'm just gonna fix this camera too just in case
all right and i you put press e on it no it's just there i
guess it's just yeah we just don't have the equipment to
tree anomalies It's not our fault.
Eye drops, maple syrup, herbs.
Herbs.
Maple syrup.
Where's the eye drops?
Oh, eye drops next to me.
I'm hungry?
Oh, oh.
Oh!
What?
I tried to date!
What do you...
Oh!
Wait, this is, oh, don't keep the hot key.
I taste him.
What do you mean?
Oh, I did this all over again.
That's it.
You missed it.
He was so hungry.
That's it.
That's, give me a sec.
I'm opening the room.
Give me a sec.
How do I open this room?
That's it.
No.
Get in here, Jack.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Wait, guys, guys.
Don't get in yet.
Don't get in.
in yet i fucked up guys don't get in yet because i need to
also join i i need to also join my own room
give me a second i did oh wait i made i just made it i just
made it just in time all right wait do i have enough to i'm
i'm no longer an intern that's it
I'm a... Oh, wait, my sanity's so low.
That's it.
I'm now a nurse.
Can I select skins?
Jesus Christ.
Okay, but they're all so cute, though.
They're all pretty cute.
Where are the skins for him?
Oh, Rass.
Okay, I was not.
Banana intern.
All right.
Here we go.
Summon the dragon stick.
worst hospital in the universe.
Patrick, I said, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank
you.
Who the fuck killed me?
Oh, I get to claim this.
Headbanger, stalker.
That guy looks like Jax from Digital Circus.
No one knows who, you only know what happens if they keep
burning.
I got everybody.
Oh, wait, I have more NPCs too.
Ron, first encounter.
Oh, there's Barney.
Raster.
I got Rathu.
All right.
Wrong treatment.
Right, target.
That's me.
It's to accidentally kill the patient, but it's okay.
It's an anomaly.
Guys, it's okay.
I killed an anomaly.
All right, guys.
Let's go.
We're going to skip tutorial too.
Oh, must I have a highest shift for or high.
All right, we're not skipping the tutorial.
All right.
Let's all do a good job here.
Wait, if one person dies, can we still keep going?
I killed a patient, but it's okay.
It's a monster.
We don't care about monster rights here in this hospital.
All right, guys.
Oh my god, it's banana.
It's banana put an intern.
I'm the head nurse here.
All right, what I say goes.
also I get coffee first all right nice I gotta wait all
right someone someone take this patient whoa all right check
this patient in all right I'll be a super since I'm the head
nurse I shall supervise you remember to take this patient in
good job you did it I take his picture and then go print and
then print it out.
Don't worry.
It's their first day, guys.
Like, teaching them.
And then you print it out.
And then...
And then, good job.
And then you give that paper to the... To him?
You give it to him?
Yes!
And now, all right.
We go to room one.
All right.
Zaz, I'll teach you the day by day.
As the head nurse.
I'll teach you how to do this.
Don't worry.
It's a healing gun.
It's a healing gun, guys.
Do not worry.
all right it's room number one all right now since we're all
right you're gonna watch me on how to do okay you take the
sample you analyze it we look at this you guys see take
notes guys it's your first day as an intern it's your first
day so you gotta know what to do and then after that scan
you look at the pc yeah and then you look at the monitor
right here yeah you need herbs i got the herbs to this
patient.
Good job.
Good job, interns.
I feel like I'm in...
I'm in... Oh, wait.
Alright.
Next patient.
Alright, let me check you in real quick.
I feel like I'm in the medical drama right now.
I'm in scrubs right now.
Our house empty.
Alright.
Room 2.
Alright, let's go to room 2, guys.
Let's go to room 2, guys.
Let's go to room too.
Next room.
What happened to the lab?
They got eaten by the mimic.
It could be lupus, guys.
Alright.
Now, did you guys remember what I did?
Take the DNA.
I'm going to test you.
If you guys remember exactly what to do.
Nice.
This could be lupus.
You don't know that.
The TV screen could say lupus right now.
Alright.
Remember to press the computer screen.
The good doctor.
Alright, we need eyedrops.
Stat!
We need eyedrops.
Oh, good job.
Good job.
The doctor.
Alright, let's see.
Alright, now the doctor's gonna give us a report on how good
we did.
I'm training the interns right now.
Only a He's getting a track, Lupus.
Yeah, yep.
These are all the new hires, Doctor.
I'm training them well.
Things get strange.
Just keep working.
Yep, you guys.
Oh!
It's the healing gun, guys.
It's the healing gun.
He's just healing the Doctor.
All right, we have the button now.
We have the shutter button.
And the security camera is operational.
Okay.
Alright, now the real game starts.
Look at that, guys.
We're doing a job well done.
I know we've got this.
Alright.
Alright, someone tell this guy to leave.
Someone talk to him.
Tell him to leave.
We don't serve anomalies here.
Sir, tell him to leave.
Okay, hi, Leo.
I'll check in as a patient.
Oh, he wants coffee.
Alright.
Let's see.
He seems to be a...
Alright.
Tell him we don't serve his kind here.
I'll be in room for.
He's a monster!
He...
They literally kill people.
It's the healing gun.
Padded it by Doki Hospital.
Doki General Hospital.
Whoa!
I literally died to one of them!
Doki, what do you mean one of them?
What do you mean?
One of them.
Somehow, always.
It was just one of, just one, just one casualty.
The hospital is only manned by one person.
All right, med kit.
I got the med kit.
And maple syrup, I got it.
Don't worry.
All right, you're healed now.
All right, we got another patient going on.
We got Rathu here.
All right, Zeph, Zeph, me and you.
you we run this we run this hospital i'm promoting you to
side intern to to go head intern not all anomalies
you're right you're not you're so right they're not actually
people
wait are you a doctor now what the fuck world you hired but
i'm the one who's not qualified bro Fizz up.
Alright.
I'm gonna supervise.
I'm supervising.
Congratulations.
You got promoted.
No additional extra pay.
Just another title.
Just a fancier title.
Oh, 69.
Nice.
Alright.
My family doesn't know I'm here.
Alright, we almost got another coffee soon.
Alright, last patient.
Okay.
All right, take a sample.
No, I'm supervising.
We did less single anomaly in this hospital in Doki Bird
General Hospital.
Yeah, my dad owns this hospital.
All right, IV drops in maple syrup.
Stat.
I got the IV.
Oh, I already got it.
It's okay.
Don't overdose him.
Don't...
No, don't overdose the patient.
Yeah, I don't need to do two years of med school.
And then I got hired by my dad.
I'm opening new facilities.
All right.
Nice, we have a supply shop now.
What do we get?
Oh, there's me.
Yay.
surprise you got tasers patients recover oh i like patient
recover i don't have the money
oh did we wait did someone buy it wait what did you guys buy
oh i'm the best i'm molly togarashi i want to check in as a
wait was this game made by japanese devs i feel like all the
last names are japanese i haven't had anything spooky yet
which is good okay when we get to the ambulance is where we
gotta freak out all right let me check is he he's real let
him in he's real not an anomaly let this man in we'll have
150 now nice just had enough all right we have upgrade to
the hospital it's got roommate all right someone let you let
this guy in i'll i'll handle this patient.
Oh, it's a surgery.
Don't worry.
The last surgery I did was a success.
On a technicality.
Technicality.
It was a success.
Ah, you're in good hands.
Do not worry.
Wait.
Oh, it's just me?
Okay.
Brain surgery.
Let's go.
Most exciting part about surgery.
Alright, cutting the brain open now.
Alright, putting a piece of meat in your brain.
Oh, putting a heart in your brain.
Can't kill the out now.
You have two hearts.
Oh my god.
Heart, scissors.
Scalpel.
Heart.
Scissors.
Putting a second heart.
Congratulations, you have three hearts now.
Yay!
I did it!
My first surgery!
My first brain surgery!
A success!
Yippee!
I knew that YouTube tutorial would help.
Alright.
Now he has three hearts.
Alright, I didn't drink this coffee.
It's hard being the head nurse.
What's that sound?
Alright, did we treat the patient number one?
yeah patient number one is okay just double checking with
all of you thanks I will be in room three all right good all
right oh it's Barry no I drank the why does Barry come
whatever guys who has ten dollars who has ten dollars for
Barry hey there friend I'm a Barney and who has ten dollars
for Barney
Does anyone have $10?
Comment up.
Oh my god, thank god.
Thanks, Fred.
Doki, I don't know what you're talking about.
I get paid minimum wage.
I will remember this.
There you go.
We just buy the robots.
Who drank the coffee last time?
Who was it?
Who did that?
Wait a minute, you're supposed to be awake for brain
surgery.
I'm sorry, I think the devs might not be medical
professionals.
You're right, can't believe they were not awake for the
three heart transplants in the brain.
Oh, these interns, they don't...
These interns, man.
They don't know they have to reserve the coffee for Barney.
I don't know where I got it.
Alright.
Yeah, he's real.
No anomaly here.
Welcome to Doki Bird Journal Hospital.
We only serve your kind.
I got room for...
We don't discriminate unless you're an anomaly!
Yeah, they don't just make interns like they used to.
That's right.
We serve everyone and everybody.
Asterisk, if you are an anomaly, please leave.
Hey, Doki, I just came back from surgery.
It looks like I have three hearts and no brain.
Should I sue for malpractice?
Look, it's not my fault.
You didn't check in the box.
We didn't know what you want for brain surgery.
We had a little checkbox before you undergo surgery.
That's, you'd be like, what do you want?
So we just assume you wanted three hearts.
Okay, Medkit, maple syrup.
more.
I got maple syrup.
You know, you can pick up more than one item.
Yeah, you're... You should sit...
Exactly.
You should sit... Why is he back?
Oh, don't open?
Open it.
As the head nurse, I asked you to open it.
What does he want?
How do we open it?
It says don't... How do we open it?
a pot I mean I guess we can't open I guess it's just there
all right time for more coffee all right one last patient
okay he seems to be like a oh what is that camera
malfunctioned around me her little zappy zap it's okay he
just has a lot of coffee he's safe don't worry i trust this
man
yeah see he's safe i would print all right
this hospital is so safe guys
all right room five last patient guys let's end this with a
bang group project this is a group this is a there's a group
teamwork operation i just woke up with three brains and no
heart how am i still alive sure i see you dragons thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you all right guys
just give him maple syrup what the fuck he's Canadian
who would have known he was just Canadian all along
All right.
It's all you want, man.
All right, herbs.
We need herbs.
Herbs, not maple syrup.
He's not Canadian.
We need herbs.
Sat.
This man's gonna die without his resident evil herbs.
All right, nice.
We did it, guys.
Good job, everybody.
Give yourself a round of applause.
Another patient saved.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't think I'm going to trust this hospital.
They let the head nurse do a triple heart surgery without...
Hey!
It was the patient's fault that he didn't stay awake.
If he was awake, he could have stopped me.
He was the one that decided to fall asleep.
Zero, they gave us super chat.
Thank you.
Make sure to use the photo and camera.
Stay alert.
I love Taser.
Alright, who wants to be the...
I'm not... I'm not Taser duty after what happened last time.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not volunteering myself for
tasers.
What's this?
Give medicine from inventory.
Use a scan.
Oh.
Use scan patient for anomalies.
I don't think that's worth it.
What's wrong with him?
Treat burns.
He has burns.
Does anyone have ointment?
Someone get this man some ointment.
Wait, this guy.
needs ointment yeah he it was from a fire oh
my god i'm trying sir sir how am i supposed to okay there
you go i was saying how am i supposed to treat your fucking
birds if you're moving see this is why you're in pain oh oh
anomaly anomaly anomaly anomaly anomaly
okay all right all right All right.
Oh, yes!
No anomalies here.
Get out.
Guys, anomaly did not show up at the hospital.
I'm just going to let everybody know there was no anomalies
in this hospital.
Guys, why did we not treat this patient?
Go treat him.
There's four of us.
What happened?
Nothing happened.
There was no anomalies that came into this hospital.
you're on no anomalies went in no anomalies went out if
you're trying are you a parent of anomaly uh sorry your son
was not did not visit this hospital you might have to write
me a file missing persons report okay room seven to keep
press conference what does he mean all right he's better now
number seven all right i got the next patient Let me double
check.
All right.
Not anomaly.
He's real.
Tony Fujita.
All right.
I had full trust in him being a real guy.
Here we go.
Thanks.
I will be in.
Whoa.
Room four.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Did we not pay for the power bills again?
guys okay you seems real all right i'm here for my
appointment oh picture oh oh oh anomaly anomaly anomaly
shoot him shoot him shoot who has a gun someone get the gun
gun shoot him shoot him yes
all right no anomalies here no get the gun
not today satan not today the treatment was successful we
did it we cured him oh shit fire are you guys had on the
fire i'll deal with this I like how everyone just ran out
when they saw fire.
You're cured now.
You no longer have to suffer.
Big guys are sad.
Alright.
Oh shit, we got Ron.
Ron's here.
Ron, my man!
See, when Anomaly becomes a corpse, it's technically not an
Anomaly.
anymore.
I never wanted to keep hiring you people because they're
doing a great job.
Never mind.
Alright.
Alright, I know you're a real.
We're doing such a good job at this hospital.
Alright, room one.
Alright, guys.
We gotta give the best care possible to Ron.
He's our accountant.
Come on.
Alright, Ron.
You get the personal head nurse treatment.
The head nurse would treat you personally.
A plus care.
My brother went to hospital the other day.
He got shot by the staff because they thought he was an
anomaly.
Should we sue Chad?
Think of the Super Chad.
Thank you, thank you.
How did you know he got shot?
Huh?
Wait a minute.
Where's your proof?
Where's your footage?
I thought, I thought so.
Or a minute bandages.
Should have read our policies.
Exactly.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So if you got shot, you wouldn't be telling anybody
anything.
So I don't think you have, I don't think...
I don't think you're telling the truth.
Oh, it's Barney.
Sure, let's take a picture of Barney.
Do we do it?
Alright, what does Barney look like?
Oh!
Do we shoot him?
Pick the shot!
You truly are, a friend.
Thanks for the photo.
okay Barney goodbye Barney he's just having a look he was
just really really stressed out he hasn't slept in five days
guys you just hasn't slept in five days no not fine not
Barney not you but I invited you to I invited you to my The
sun's bar mitzvah!
And two, Barney?
What's up?
I'm buddy budding.
Okay, not anomaly guys.
Not anomaly.
He's safe.
Yeah, I told you he's safe.
I can smell anomaly from five miles away.
All right, last patient.
Patient room three.
All right, guys.
there's gonna be a group project everybody come on you are
my daughter's wedding oh let's clean this up sorry he had a
little accident guys he's very very unwell don't you hate it
when you just poop a slime in the hospital God sorry he has
slime vid let's understand all right guys group effort Wait.
We're all gonna fix you.
Alright.
What do we need?
Ointment.
Just ointment.
Alright.
For his bottle.
The slime burned it.
Definitely was burning it out.
Alright, nice.
The doctors.
Alright, let's see what the doctor was.
Oh, shit.
It's hospital time.
Guys, this is very important.
There's been an anomaly attacked.
All right, guys, we got this.
This is what we trained for, everybody.
We trained for it at this exact moment.
This is it.
Our training.
This is our training.
All right.
Here we go.
One of them will faint.
All right, someone get number three.
Someone get green.
Someone get red.
get yellow someone oh that that's an anomaly that's no oh my
god wait
okay i got the fireman oh assistance required oh i need an
ointment oh my god guys guys guys do not panic do not panic
everyone do not panic okay okay all right okay Oh my god.
In.
Room 5.
Uh, 5.
I got 5.
Okay.
Maple syrup bandage.
Okay, you got 5.
Okay.
Uh.
Oh, God.
I got 6.
doing a surgery.
Okay.
Uh, red.
Blue.
Red.
Red, blue, red, yellow.
blue, red, yellow.
Oh, someone died.
It's okay.
They were anomaly!
Oh, God.
Okay, okay.
Someone do eight!
Okay.
Oh, no one's doing the surgery, guys.
No one's doing the surgery.
Medkit.
It's okay.
They were anomaly!
All right, all right, all right.
I don't have a surgery.
No!
Someone saved the head nurse!
It's okay.
Okay.
All right.
We're fine.
It's just okay.
I just need to get some coffee.
I just need to get the coffee.
Bro is not qualified for this.
I went to the hospital and the head nurse had been away for
five days.
about the obelisans seated and she tried to give me three
hard chestlets i'm scared bro this is all i can afford yeah
she went to the private hospital she got health insurance
that's on you it's a don't worry coffee makes it all right
give it up for day six day six of my shift i'm on a i'm on a
60 hour shift right now
The captain, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
More ambulances will come.
Be prepared.
Here is a bonus for your work.
We did it, guys.
We did it, everybody.
No one died.
Yay!
We're so good at our jobs.
I know I did it.
We're so good at what we do.
I'm walked through junk.
Fudge, thank you, a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doc, I came to the hospital because I have rash only to
get shot for being an anomaly.
Does my insurance cover this?
That's your fault for being an anomaly.
Maybe it shouldn't have been an anomaly, huh?
Have you ever thought about that?
All right, room two.
Room two, everyone.
All right, let me double check the security camera.
rub.
Guys, someone slimed on the floor.
Can someone clean up?
Clean up on aisle one.
We got slime on the floor.
Alright.
He needs coffee.
Who drank the coffee again?
Guys, come on.
We know Barney is coming.
Oh, we got another one?
Okay.
Can I bother you with a scalpel?
Alright.
How do we give him a scalpel?
I'll get him the scalpel.
Don't worry, I got this.
I know where the scalpel is at.
Alright, I got it.
He's not gonna stab me, right?
Wait, did you give it to him already?
Wait, what did he say?
Oh, what did he say?
Alright, I guess I'll never know.
I guess I'll never know.
what he said.
Oh, it's Ron.
Hey, Ron.
You can always trust Ron.
Still here?
Yeah.
I got eaten by the bed monster.
The last guy got eaten by the bed monster.
I think he got the wrong hospital.
That's not our hospital.
That's why I always carry maple.
Oh, that's why they teach you about the maple syrup.
Can't believe the bed monster is Canadian.
And you can always trust Ron.
he's just tired not anomaly that's just how he looks okay
which one's mine oh this is mine all right room one don't
worry Ron I'll personally tend to you with my assistant
don't worry Ron for our VIP customers you will get the
dokeybird treatment okay Come on, Ron.
Oh, shit, a fire.
Fire!
Also, we had slime started here.
We got needed someone to clean the slime.
And also a visitor fainted.
We don't pay you to, like, lounge around.
Alright, Ron.
What do you have?
Alright.
Let's see.
Pop syrup.
Maple syrup.
Alright.
Carp syrup and maple syrup.
Oh.
Oh, almost catch you open, right?
That would have been pretty bad.
Whoops.
Almost stabbed you, right?
Oh, was he an anomaly?
Oh, shit!
Don't worry.
Nothing wrong going here.
Don't worry, he was just at the wrong hospital.
I have an appointment?
Alright.
Let's see.
Yep.
Seems to have you in the database.
Oh, it's Rathu!
I am a good guy.
I know.
I Rathu.
Just to be sure, Rathu.
It's gotta be true.
Look at him just.
Yippee!
Surgery!
He's just asking for direction.
What the fuck?
I couldn't even get in the fucking past the lobby.
Guys, our security is so good.
And all of a sudden, yippee!
Stop my surgery!
Alright, I got... He's got room 7.
Alright, let me double check.
Okay.
Seems normal.
Yep.
Gotta print it out.
Alright.
Alright, no more pay.
Alright, it's time to heal.
Oh, we did it!
Alright.
We have Rathu coming in hot.
Alright, Rathu.
You get the personal Doki.
treatment because you're a special mpc i only handle the
special ones all right so all right give him the iv i got
the osu lined up and ready
all right do that good job intern now let the real nurse do
the real job
watch the real nurse in action no longer baby internship now
Alright, heart scan complete.
Yeah, what do you have?
Alright, oh 69, nice.
Alright, dried eyes and fever.
Eye drops, thermo.
Alright, let's go.
Eye drops and thermo.
I got the eye drops.
Hey!
This is my very special patient.
We'll catch you.
Alright.
Our doctor is here.
What is he going to reward us now?
Your sanity is important.
Don't die on me.
What happens if one of us dies?
And take care of the patients.
I mean, that's what we've been doing all along.
It's the hostile reports.
Records three deaths is over.
Not us.
Oh, we've been doing such a good job.
I like how now it shows up.
Nice.
All right, good.
All right, what does the hospital have?
Any upgrades?
Any good upgrades?
Oh, we got the computer.
What's this?
Deploy security.
Oh, we don't need that.
All right, shift number.
Oh, it's Barney.
You let me hide with you for a bit.
Something came up?
What happened?
Barney?
Alright.
Who is he hiding with?
Me?
Oh.
I feel much safer now.
Where is he gonna hide?
Is he real?
Yeah.
He's real.
Alright.
I guess I'll protect you.
You have to be better.
Oh!
All right.
That's the full whammy.
Wait, someone quit.
Get tofu.
No anomalies allowed.
It's not overkill, guys.
It's not overkill.
Want to know a secret?
Okay.
They're testing something here.
Testing what?
Patients, they're not sick.
They're infected.
What?
I just gave him a little bandage.
What does he mean by that?
What does Ron mean?
But, like, I did surgery.
I did brain surgery.
I...
He doesn't mean...
I did brain surgery on a rat.
Okay, roommate.
Don't worry, Ron.
Um, I got Ron.
Stop animal testing.
Secret animal testing hospital.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Okay, it's X-ray.
Alright.
Ron, I got you.
I wonder if you can accidentally kill Ron.
Yeah, he's an accountant.
What does he know?
Green.
Blue.
Alright.
green blue blue blue okay that's not like the smartest
pattern i i've given myself look i just knew what blue was
the different was the other blue all right canadian wait ron
you're canadian i knew i felt i knew i felt connection to
you the moment you walked in
don't worry we're fixing the canadian i'm gonna watch him he
did it congratulations on a successful surgery all right oh
it's rafu oh patient's on fire oh shit oh oh okay i got him
i got him i got him enough fire okay we gotta get ointment
someone do deal with the fire i'm gonna get the burn
ointment
got it
all right oh he's already cured oh yeah i think he's dead
i'm pretty sure he's dead i mean yeah i think he's fine i
think we took a picture when he was still like on fire so it
should be fine all right room seven Oh, shit, wait, was he
not dead dead?
All right, room seven.
Who's in room four?
Is he here already?
Oh, oh, Ratfew, don't worry.
First, you're a VIP patient here, and I got you, Ratfew.
No, he was a nominee.
You can tell because of the dislocated jaw.
Alright, Raffew, medicine.
Okay, just medicine.
It just has a little cold.
Don't worry.
Just a little sore throat.
Let me stuff all this inside you, Raffew.
You're cured.
Oh, shit.
Is that a hospital?
What's going on?
This time you guys need to come through the back door.
I got new hires, but they're a bit nosy.
I'll tell you, I can wear some a day later today.
Be prepared.
What's going on?
Animal Corporation?
Oh.
Oh, maybe he's getting the new brain transplants, you know?
I think that's it.
Guys, the doctor got a new shipment of brains.
Guys?
He just has a new shipment of brains.
Nothing more, nothing less.
Where do you think he gets all the hearts and the organs
from?
The back door has a cooler.
Alright, it's Ozu time.
Oh.
C7, 73.
Oh my god, we need more.
Please, we need more non-skulls.
Alright, nice.
Alright, scan.
Oh, I need to drink some coffee soon.
I'm getting a bit stressed out.
Bandage, thermo.
Alright.
Thermo.
Bandage.
I got you.
Thermo.
Yo, Kirich, sir.
Do we do anything with this guy yet?
Oh, shit.
Don't look up.
Okay, we did.
Alright.
Are these guys fine?
Oh, they're fine.
Alright.
Get in.
Room 1.
Nothing wrong here.
We're doing so well.
Proud of us.
I'm so proud of us.
Good job.
Good job, interns.
We're going to get a five-star review soon.
Maybe the government will finally give us a grant.
Alright.
Let's do one.
Oh, yeah.
You got one?
I'm going to go five.
Nobody died.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Don't worry, I got my eyedrops and my ointment ready.
And my scalpel.
What's the diagnostics?
Maple syrup.
Medkit herbs.
Okay, so none of the things I had.
I got the maple syrup.
I got the medkit.
I got the herbs.
Okay, someone else has to get the herbs.
Someone else has to get the herbs.
Herbs.
That's right.
Do your job.
Do the job that you're not paid to do.
Barney, are you okay now?
Thanks again for calling us this friend.
There's a trash can.
This will be important!
What if someone has really, really dry eyes?
And I have five seconds to give this to them.
Wait, we have one more patient.
Who still has not been cured?
Yeah.
Okay, it's that guy.
guy all right he's gonna be cured soon wait what was he
anomaly this entire time what happened to him all right well
he was filled yay Barney lose we did it Oh, hey.
Hello.
I'm Officer Duckman.
Those eyes.
I don't know if I can trust those eyes.
We're currently tracking a dangerous serial killer.
This is a picture.
Have you seen him?
Do
we do it?
Oh.
Party.
It's parties.
It's my Barney's friend.
Okay, wait.
First off, we gotta get this lady in here first.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Let me turn this lady in.
We didn't see anybody.
Sir?
Nope.
No Barney is here.
Alright.
Do you see anything suspicious?
Let me know.
Oh.
No Barney's here!
No, no.
Snitches get stitches.
Barney.
Are you?
Oh.
Yes, you'd befriend the serial killer.
You wouldn't get sad.
I think I'm some kind of anomaly.
But you treat me just like anyone else.
He is the serial killer.
Oh, you were the one that said that.
Oh, just because you're a rat?
Alright, let me make this for Ratthew.
Yeah, I was gonna say, that's Ratthew's talking.
Alright, I need to drink coffee.
I'm getting a little stressed out here.
Guys, guys, are you befriending Siri Killer?
You'll be like, Hey, I like you.
Don't come to school tomorrow.
Alright, yeah, plus 10 NPC speed.
You know what?
Because I want a gun.
I'm going to clean up a slime.
So where's the trash can?
Where does Rathu go?
Oh, Rathu.
Hey, hey, hey.
Rathu is my patient.
Green, red, pink, yellow.
all right
try to blow my nose uh ivy drops medkit okay ivy drops all
right let me okay i'll put the scalpel away ivy drops medkit
there we go all right don't worry raffi i got you i'm gonna
shot you but i got you hey what's wrong with him oh he's
just a visitor Why is he just sitting there?
Guys, I have a gun.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for any anomalies.
Alright, Taro.
Room 8 and room 3.
Don't worry.
I'm ready to save the world.
Oh, he pooped.
Somebody clean up the poop.
Yeah, I got...
Oh, yeah.
He's wearing blue slippers now.
Oh, it's surgery time.
Wait, I don't want to do the surgery.
Oh, it's Ron!
Ron, my man!
Alright, Ron.
What you got for me?
I work for the corporation.
The corporation?
Damn, you must have paid extra for the trademark.
All the eyes and stuff.
Oh, shit.
You double tap.
That's why I cough.
is important.
Well, I know you're real.
Ron.
Ron, the accountant.
He's from the corpa.
Guys, a D.
Oh, shit!
Wait, wait, wait!
You beat!
Shot my first anomaly!
I did it!
Guys, no one's Oh, wait, he's doing the surgery.
He's gonna make it.
I did it, guys!
I shot my first man!
Oh, oh!
I don't think we should live.
I like how all of us just...
Hmm.
Okay.
All right, Zach's no longer on surgery duty.
He's no longer allowed to do surgery.
I like how we all of us turned around and look at the
fucking door and be like, who did it?
Who was it?
We all looked at the door too.
Uh-oh.
He's about to get fired.
All right, Zax is now bad from doing surgery.
Bro, like we all, like I was like, bro, what did you do?
Oh, no, all the paperwork.
We're going to do so much paperwork now.
Zax, at least clean the slime.
A patient pooped on you.
All right.
At least clean the slime.
Alright, yeah, we're all like, are you serious, bro?
Alright, cough syrup, ointment.
Cough, syrup.
Oh my god, get the fire, use the ointment!
Let's go!
Oh yeah.
Do we do it?
Or are you just...
Okay, cough syrup, maple syrup.
Oh, I got you.
That's right.
I did your job for you.
Yay!
Wow, why do we have one...
Wow!
Hospital poor!
So cute.
might need to be fired today.
Oh, I have new supplies.
What's this?
Faster DNA analysis?
I have the money for it.
Let's make them faster.
I think he's...
He's an anomaly, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was like, right?
Just gotta be sure.
I just want to be Oh, oh, shit.
All right, someone carry him.
Someone carry him!
Set!
What just...
What just happened?
What is he real, though?
Is he really?
What?
No one will ever know.
Reduce, reuse, recycle, guys.
It works.
I'm gonna drink this coffee.
It is from the lack of sleep, guys.
Maybe, guys, it was just from the lack of sleep.
We did not know what we just saw.
Wait, all right, someone has to do surgery, dude, and it's
not me.
And not Zach's, too.
Ever read the hospital discharge logs?
I don't know, Irene.
The courts are owned this place, but they hide the logs.
Zero medical waste.
Pretty sketchy.
Alright, there was no...
Guys, guys, we got to dispose medical waste.
Guys.
We have to dispose medical waste.
I'll be in room 8.
Alright.
Wait, he's gonna be in room 8?
We already have someone in room 8.
What the fuck?
Room 8 is occupied.
Run.
What?
Are we double booking room 8?
Um...
Hey, so...
He's gonna be in room 8 as well.
well.
Oh, what?
That bad?
Huh?
Oh, he's visiting him.
Don't look up.
I mean, he's okay.
Your friend's okay.
Your friend lives.
Don't worry.
We don't talk about the other patient.
Is that Raffew?
Raffew, my boy!
Okay, I got Raffew.
Yeah, he's just visiting.
All right, Raffu.
What do you have for me today?
I may need... Raffu, no!
We're friends!
I thought we were best friends!
The Animal Corporation is after me?
Oh my god, you gotta go to Witness Protection?
But first, I want to chat with you.
Oh, because we're best friends.
Okay.
I trust Raffu with my life.
All right, Raphael.
Let's go.
All right, one last treatment, Raphael.
Oh.
Raphael?
Oh, okay.
Hey.
Oh.
Oh shit, I got a gun!
Don't worry!
Oh shit, don't worry, he's fine, right?
We did it!
Alright.
Alright, let me double check.
It seemed to be good people, yeah?
Alright, Mr. Cookie.
Get in there.
It's the end.
Alright, you two, get in there.
We saved him.
Wait, he didn't pay the...
Wait, he didn't pay the bill.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait.
Patience on fire.
Patience is on fire.
I have ointment.
I knew this ointment would come in handy.
All right.
There you go.
You seem to be a real guy because you were on fire.
Yeah, he's real.
Don't worry.
No shots here.
Yeah, Raffi's just a little guy.
He just wanted...
It's like, take your rat to work day.
You know?
Wait, that's a ghost.
Wait, that's a...
He just shot him.
I mean, sure.
I just shot the ghost.
I mean, hey, if it works.
If it works, guys.
guys.
Just shoot the ghost.
Alright, let's go.
Check on the remaining patients.
See if they're all cured.
Tazers.
I don't know if he tased them.
We've shot him.
I guess we work on... We're ghostbusters on a side.
Maple syrup.
Medicine.
Bandage.
Okay.
Maple syrup.
Medicine.
Bandage.
Maple syrup.
Okay.
Alright.
You're cured.
4.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Alright.
What's wrong with you, sir?
10-20%.
Medkit.
Alright.
Kid time.
Alright, what about you?
Guys, why are no one treating the patient?
God, there's five of us.
There's four, sorry.
I'm on my 10th shift right now.
I'm on my 80th hour shift right now.
I'm not clocked out yet.
I've started seeing doubles.
Okay, IV drops.
Alright.
Bam.
We did it.
I won't have like the others now.
Of course not.
You're in safe hands.
No, no, no goodbye.
What do you want?
Like, what do you want?
I did everything I could.
All right.
Um.
I got...
Oh, someone did do the...
I...
No!
Do the surgery!
Okay.
Room 8.
I got room 1.
Okay.
Wait.
Someone...
do eight someone do eight i i refuse to do surgery
so someone do eight he's just dying
all right oh i didn't look wait i didn't look at it wait
what was i looked at this chat guys guys what was it i was
looking at chat guys what was the sequence
Guys, guys, blue, blue, red, what else?
Yellow, blue.
All right, I hope someone's doing the surgery right now.
I hope someone's doing the surgery.
I'm going to look to the side and hope surgery is being
done.
Was that the...
Oh, that was him.
That...
Okay, Ornament, IV...
I was like, guys, what's going on?
I hear growling.
I did.
I'm a hero.
Weird.
Yeah, I just saved my staff's life.
I was like, hey, guys, what's all the sound up there?
Let's see.
Rathu.
No, did I miss out on your lore?
Wait, someone started... No!
I was performing surgery!
Alright, who's got the...
Oh, I'm not about this.
Faster computer.
Oh, oh, no, no, no.
Rathu!
No!
Not the Lord.
Okay, I need coffee, though.
We both need coffee.
What?
You guys hear that?
There'd not be something creepy going on.
Yes, we have to restart.
No, that's alright, guys.
That's alright.
He's still recovering.
Recover faster.
Or we're adding another 100 grand.
Alright.
nice we did it yeah we're so good at our jobs bonus a
hundred dollars oh okay where did he come from oh hey Ron
Ron's back oh the camera's broken all right I'll deal with
Ron you fix the camera they moved the old files last month
Said it was a routine cleanup.
A lot of smoke for a routine cleanup.
Alright.
Well, I know I can always trust on you, Ron.
Guys, we had a fire that started our roommate.
Room 1, I got Ron!
Ron's mine!
Wait, who's that?
Wait, that guy's new.
Who are you?
I've never seen you before.
Hi, my name is Lizbeth.
But you can call me Liz.
Okay.
I used to work for Animal Corp's news channel, but I was
fired.
I had a huge scoop, but they said it was fake.
Ah!
I know!
Take my UV camera.
Oh?
I snap a photo of Ren Hayashi with it.
Will you help me with this?
Sure.
Alright, guys.
Ren Hayashi.
How will I know who's Ren Hayashi?
Alright, sure.
Are you Ren Hayashi?
No, you're a pumpkin.
Okay.
Remember, they need to be at the check-in window for it to
work.
All right, guys, I'm handling all check-ins now.
Now I need to go.
See you soon.
I need Ren Hayashi.
What's your name?
All right.
Where's my camera?
Where's the camera?
Where is it?
Liz never gave me the camera okay midnight camera don't go
all right who has the camera who has oh wait anomaly anomaly
wait actually don't don't shoot him yet don't shoot him yet
i don't know his name what is his name
what's his name oh that's not max shoot this guy okay wait I
have a gun all right now I shoot this guy all right there
you go now you may go in now okay all right that's that's
okay yeah no okay that's the camera okay wait wait it could
be red ayashi okay What's his name?
That could have been Ren Hayashi!
Okay, stop going!
Alright, someone treat this guy's burn.
Oh, no.
We don't know if that was Ren Hayashi, guys.
We'll never know.
Okay, that's Sarah.
Alright, what's your name?
Okay, You could be Ren Hayashi.
Okay, that's Mika.
You're five.
All right, what's your name?
Okay, you are definitely not real.
Oh, yeah, no, shoot him.
Is he dead?
Is he...
There we go.
Now he's dead, dead.
What's the lord?
Liz, I know a little bit about her.
She worked for her.
She's new in town.
A recent graduate.
But she got fired.
I don't know the reason.
And not ask questions.
Sigh.
Wait, Ren Hayashi never came.
Guys, I think we shot Ren Hayashi.
I think...
The one guy we accidentally shot.
I think that was Ren Hayashi.
No!
We didn't get his name!
That was Ren Hayashi.
We never got his name.
Maybe he's going to come over in the next...
Guys, maybe he'll show up next round.
Guys, maybe he'll show up.
Maybe he needs eyedrops.
His eyes might be really, really dry.
Okay, cough syrup.
You deal with that.
You handle the cough syrup.
I'll check on number four.
Oh, never mind.
I'm done.
Rehayashi!
Who are you?
Guys, I'll handle receptionists.
Don't shoot anyone till I tell you to.
Alright.
Okay.
Don't shoot anybody unless I say so.
Don't shoot?
Okay.
Sora Fox.
You're 5.
Just oh shit don't shoot him.
Don't shoot him though.
Do not shoot him I need to know if he's Ren Hayashi Okay,
you can shoot him now.
You can shoot him you can shoot him you can shoot him Yeah,
yeah, yeah, that's yeah, that's not Ren Hayashi.
We gotta find Ren Hayashi
Okay.
Alright, not Renayashi, but I gotta be sure if you're real.
Alright, he's real.
He's a real man.
Just in case.
Hey, Ryan.
It's hitting me in the ceiling.
The doctor at the time panicked looking for eyedrops.
Oh my god, maybe that's Renayashi.
And then poof, he was gone.
Guys, this could be...
Whoa!
Why did you...
That could be Red Hayashi!
That could have been Red Hayashi!
We'll never know, Mr. Red Hayashi.
We'll never know.
I've been trying to find Mr. Red for so long.
When will Ren show up?
When will he show up?
Will the real Ren please stand up?
We'll never know.
Who even is Ren?
Oh my god.
We just need Ren Hayashi so I can take the stupid UV for
you.
Oh, no
Okay Oh my god, Renayashi right now.
Yes, he is here.
He's here.
It's mr.
Renayashi
He's a vampire What do I do with that?
Do we kill him?
What do I do now?
Yeah, yeah, I got food.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got the food right here.
Yeah.
Haru Wubo.
Guys, guys, I got Haru Wubo.
Guys.
Anyways, where we found red.
Yeah, yeah, we sure did.
All right, Haru Wubo.
Guys, I got, I'm mad at the station.
Do not shoot anybody, guys.
Do not shoot anybody.
I need to find Haru Wubo.
Oh, shit.
Okay, you can shoot her, though.
But you can shoot her.
You can shoot her.
She's fine.
All right, we gotta get Haru Wubo.
All right.
All right, somebody get that patient that's on fire.
I'm trying to find Haru Wubo right now.
Hey, Sammy.
Oh, my gosh.
Fix the camera.
Wait.
Fix the camera in the lobby.
Oh, wait.
Whoa!
all right you seem to be not enough you're fine you're i
didn't kill anybody i didn't do nothing all right haru
wobble all right let's check the camera oh yeah there we go
a good job yes guy all right zoe oh my god what okay you're
fine i'm just gonna here you go
guys just don't look at him he just wants he's just what
just wants attention just don't look at him guys just don't
look at him He's just begging for attention, guys.
He's just an attention whore.
Haru-woobo.
Is this Haru-woobo?
Are you Haru-woobo?
Okay, you are not Haru-woobo.
Oh my god, please, just let me look at her.
Oh my god, Cassie!
I'm just trying to dump!
Oh my god, someone get rid of him!
I can't tell if Haru-Wu-Bah!
If this person is an anomaly or not.
Alright, you seem fine.
Fuck it.
I like to say with Mint-T.
Nice like this.
And one thing that sells me anymore.
It's quiet tonight.
Too quiet.
It's been terrible happening long ago.
I won't bore you with it.
There was before you.
It hasn't been the same since.
can bards me never came back the corporation they saved me
what is left of me i work for them now we all do in the end
once the research is done everything will be better more
patience no more knights like this you'll see everyone will
see all right don't look at him don't look at him guys
that's what he wants okay we gotta treat four more patients
there.
I got patient number three.
Don't worry.
All right.
Oh, he's fake posting.
Sir, can you stop fake posting?
What are those fake posting memes?
Orient men.
Oh my god, the eyedrocks finally.
My time to shy.
You got it.
SpongeBob.
Oh my god, stop.
do we do it um do you not did oh did you all fucked up did
you not look at this oh my god i swear to god we don't we
have a problem we might have a problem
Is SpongeBob the only competent intern in this entire
hospital?
Oh my god, there's a goddamn death ritual right now.
Alright, he's fine.
So we do have a problem in room 6.
Okay.
well then it looks like someone's gonna have to die
that's good oh my god okay we get round two all right i have
to use the bathroom haru wubel remember all right guys you
guys gotta handle hard oh wait actually i'll look at the
lore and then i gotta use the bathroom after the lore Thank
God we have round two of x-ray.
Thank God our patient didn't die of radiation poisoning
Thank fucking God Who got where did we get these interns
anyway?
I got the thermostat
All right, you're cured now I stuck it up your ass
All right Zero deaths.
Let's go.
All right Someone has to... Alright, someone has to deal
with Haru Wubo.
I have to pee.
I'll be right back, everybody.
I trust in all of you.
Alright.
Wait, I got Ron.
Wait, Ron.
Ron, Ron.
He's our man.
And then I'll go pee.
I feel like someone's watching from the corner of your eye.
I mean, their doctor's here.
Yeah.
I used to work with that guy.
Okay, Haru Wubo?
Let's see.
Haru Wubo?
No, it's not.
Not to stare at him.
He is shy.
That guy?
All right.
Make sure to take a picture of Haru Wuba.
Oh, wait.
Okay, wait.
Actually, I'm going to hold it in a little bit.
That could be her.
Guys, don't shoot her.
That could be Haru Wuba.
I have to know.
Okay, that's not Haru Wuba.
you can you can shoot her now all right all
right let me double check if she's fine all right yeah she's
okay all right are you haru wubu no your dojo all right you
seem to be fine too okay i have emergency horse that needs
magnify is this where i bring him yes we do we do treatments
and horse magnifying we do it all yeah okay not haru wubo
one day one of you will be haru wubo i've been thinking of
the super chat thank you thank you one day
i'm not even checking if you're a real patient too i just i
Nina, no, are you?
Okay, midnight Sasaki.
Nope, you're not Haru Wuba.
Haru Wuba?
Oh, it's Haruuba!
Picture!
Take a picture!
Oh my god, is that?
Haruuba!
Alright, do we let her in?
I mean, last time I... We can let her in, right?
Because I shot her last time.
This is on you, SpongeBob.
As head intern, I let you decide.
I mean, other than...
It's fine, right?
There you go.
Alright, I go pee now.
I'll be right back, guys.
Wait, actually, it's treatment time.
Alright.
I'll stand here.
Alright, someone treat her while I go use the bathroom.
Did my interns do it?
Oh my god, we're shifters.
13.
What's going on, guys?
Oh my god, man!
Yippee!
I did it!
As the head nurse, I will take all the credit.
Why is there one animal death?
Guys?
Guys.
Why?
Why is there one?
Who died?
Who did...
Who...
Who died?
Wait, there's a ghost.
There's a ghost here.
Yeah, someone shoot the ghost.
Someone shoot the ghost.
As soon as I left someone died.
Oh, shit, I got a drink of coffee.
That was my own office once.
Oh, it's Ratthew.
Chew through some experimental person I was supposed to see.
Did me a favor, honestly.
He's a real guy.
Alright, Ron.
Don't worry, Ron.
Since I found Haru Wubo.
We're gonna work together again.
All right.
I caught dibs on Ron.
All right, someone get the patient that's on fire.
Oh, I hear something on fire, Ron.
Let's go, Ron.
You're, oh.
Ghostly presence.
Oh, shit.
Where is he?
Where's the ghost?
All right, nice.
We shot him.
Thank God.
Thank God we have ghost bullets.
All right, Ron, let's go.
Personal doctor is here.
You got the VIP, VVIP treatment, Ron.
Right here.
All right, let's see.
What do you suffer from?
Canadian?
Oh, just some...
It's like a werewolf, you know?
If he doesn't get his maple syrup, he's going to turn
Canadian.
No!
He's going to let the wolf out.
Get that Canadian out.
The full moon.
The Tim Hortons is out tonight.
Each patient you have in top 10 photos of has something in
common.
Do you do?
You have come here before.
Oh!
Each patient visits a hospital multiple times across the
week.
I mean, before you work here, they were coming.
Now, next photo, my sale.
Alright, guys, I got my sale.
Alright, I'm back on reception, duty.
Is this my?
That's Max.
Is he a real cat?
Are you gonna shoot him?
So you knew what the fuck you want with him.
There's another ghost in the lobby.
Oh, yeah, no, that's not.
Guys, shoot him again.
Alright, there we go.
I was like, where did my gun go?
Those goddamn ghosts.
Wait, did someone else transform?
Guys, I don't have guns anymore, so someone has to deal with
that.
Are you my?
No, you're Lola.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
I think he's dead.
Are you my?
Okay, Shadow Yosh.
Alright.
Are you a good guy, though?
Oh, yeah.
He's fine.
Alright, what about you?
all right you seem fine oh my my photo photo photo photo oh
shit i got my trip passed through a ghost
oh shit all right bring her in bring her in guys hope you're
not new nope I'm on my 80 I'm on 120 of our shift right now.
Oh shit.
Okay, shoot him.
Someone shoot him Oh shit.
Who has a gun?
That that's an anomaly.
Someone shoot him.
We need gun.
SOS gun.
There we go.
All right, nice.
All right, now I get to Now I have to treat my patients.
All right, here we go.
The shutters are free.
Yeah.
Okay, dark blue.
Pink.
Yeah, but shooting them means they won't come back.
But gun.
Yeah, but gun is more fun.
It's true.
Okay, maple syrup, bandage.
Maple syrup, bandage.
All right, here we go.
Wait, where did my bandage go?
Oh, did I just double oxen?
Oh, my God.
He's performing a surgery.
From where I got you.
I did it.
Guys, I did the surgery.
Yeah, but the pistol heals, guys.
Oh, no.
okay i don't know which one's the anomaly so someone with
the guns better have the anomaly okay all right don't worry
i got you all right we have to do the emergency ones okay
critical patient in three okay i'll get the fire one
okay room five okay i got page i got room so far
All right.
Room four is in with me.
Okay.
Maple syrup.
Herbs.
All right.
We got it.
Patient critical room number five.
Room three and seven.
Three and seven.
I repeat.
I got seven.
Oh, shit.
No, it's Osu.
Don't worry.
I'm ready.
I'm queued up.
Oh, we got it.
We got it.
How are you still scanning?
Look, look.
Bandage.
I drop.
I'm running.
Boom.
dodged
dodged perfectly all right we fixed it we not have guns
anymore wait are you okay I heard I heard a it'll be all
right it's just a flesh wound guys just a little oh I should
drink coffee too don't worry just a little flesh wound we
get everybody oh we didn't check the shop oh I have a I can
buy a gun so yeah everybody's alive so I don't need to use a
revive oh maple we forgot about this guy whoops we're like
everyone's cured except for him fuck that guy
All right, patient on fire.
Oh, my God, already we just opened the hospital.
When does the shift end?
All right.
All right, these are real people.
Real men.
Real guy.
Not that guy, though.
Don't worry.
Someone double tap him.
There we go.
I got it.
Alright.
Alright, don't mind.
Oh, shit.
Someone take him.
I got Ron.
The most important one.
We've been working so hard.
We can't rest.
The boss is furious.
Why did I accept this job?
I need to get treated before the meeting with him.
Alright, don't worry.
Your favorite doctor nurse is here.
Alright, alright.
Ryan.
All right, someone else mad at the receptionist.
Ryan's personal nurse is here to treat him.
All right, Ryan.
Oh, wait, there's more stuff at the shop now.
What's this?
Plus 10%.
I feel like we need that.
All right, now they're even faster.
Don't worry.
Your personal nurse is here to treat you.
You got a BVVV VIP treatment.
what hello where did they go are you a visitor he said this
was the room oh all right I'll let you okay I'll let you do
your thing oh I'll take DNA sample maybe Ron is might not be
very stable guys just a maze me okay ointment maple syrup
medkit okay maple syrup ornament medkit might be a little
puku just a little maybe not all there oh shit mccurdo woods
all right you guys handle that i'll let you guys deal with
mccurdo woods i want to treat i'm here to save lives
I'm here to save lives.
You guys find Makoto Woods.
You know what?
Get ready.
I'm going to perform surgery.
Watch this.
I'm coming out of retirement.
Alright.
I'm going to prep you up for surgery now.
surgery oh my specialty don't worry it's not my first time
doing brain surgery it's my second time okay medicine it's
the right oh antibiotics don't worry i know what i'm doing
all right scalpel all right heart med kit
Oh.
Bam.
Cured.
Close.
You now have three hearts in your brain.
Medicine, med kit.
Oh, thank God I already got the medicine.
It's because I could see the future.
I knew he needed medicine.
I just saw the future.
All right, there we go.
Oh, we're back.
You were going to watch me shoot my gun.
Did we get Makoto Woods yet?
Wait, whose box is this?
What?
A monster emerged in room 8.
There you go.
We're fine.
It's okay, everyone.
No.
It's okay, guys.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Nothing happened.
It's rewind time.
Guys, have we seen...
Have we seen Makoto Woods yet?
Don't worry.
We paid.
cover-up.
It's lore time.
Yeah?
Is he gonna say anything?
Hello?
Is that it?
A new shipment, new raw supplies.
Please see it personally.
Okay.
Oh, it's Ron!
Hey, Ron!
Oh, I hope there's nobody at the receptionist.
Contacts, records.
Who knows?
and put
my paper back work back where it belongs
that's it is that everything oh what's in here oh look it's
a photo of his family now the paperwork won't sign itself
call 808 for cleanup alright I guess that's it we couldn't
alright that's the end of that story oh it's animal corp oh
wait we we're we're basically next to animal corp
okay treat two patients remaining
oh i missed half the combo because i wasn't looking at him i
was just i'm sorry i couldn't help it i i was so guys ron's
my man ron ron he's the man I'm Ron's.
I'm sorry.
I've only asked for one over one animal and it's Ron the
accountant.
Guys, does anyone know who the guy we're supposed to take a
photo of?
Guys, he's my VV VIP patient.
He's about to...
all right well i should drink coffee though
look i saw ron talking about rat view
i was so focused on that because we're so good at this game
we're progressing where no rat has progressed before we
forgot to treat number six we forgot about number six oh no
he's still he's taking 80 years to recover
It was the only last time I'll ever hear about Ratfew.
How many shifts does this game have?
Who killed it?
Who killed it, got?
Yo, B5.
Guys, who remembers the name of the person we're supposed to
take a picture of?
Because it's not me.
I absolutely do not know who we're supposed to take a
picture of.
Oh.
Oh, the stalker's back.
We'll print faster.
All right.
Pumpkin spice Finley.
Okay, I don't think it's either of these guys.
Oh, shit.
He fainted.
All right.
Bring him in.
Don't worry, I got him.
Okay, you got him.
All right, it's somebody's job to...
All right, I'll cure this guy.
Take a picture.
Makoto.
it was?
Alright, I hope they know that.
Alright.
Medicine, eye drops.
Let's see.
Alright.
Oh, it's next to him.
Oh, very convenient, though.
Alright.
Congratulations, you're cured.
Oh my god, I thought that was an anomaly.
Alright, I'll get number 7 as well.
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, he's heading in there.
I was gonna say.
Ghost patient?
I'm in the same sense.
Pirate and V never comes back.
The corporation.
Oh, wait.
We already saw that lore.
It's the same lore.
Makoto Woods.
Remember, Makoto Woods.
Um.
Well, let's hope one of them is not Makoto Woods.
Bell.
Makoto Woods.
Take a picture.
Alright, we got it.
her oh shit do we do we shoot her okay we might need a
shooter okay and we have to shoot her too all right we got
Makoto Woods we did it all right back in business we go can
you know coffee though all right now we go back to business
Self-defense.
It was self-defense, guys.
We did it!
That's exactly what I needed.
With these photos, I can finally publish my story.
Also, this guy is safe.
They didn't fire me because it was fake.
They fired me because it was true.
Oh, she's totally dead.
They're gonna kill her.
She's gonna be standing next to a window soon all right nice
bye Liz all right yeah she's real all right here you go
thank you come again because we'll we'll need you to pay for
pay uh for a hospital all right time to see I'll deal with
patient.
Oh, you got patient too?
I'll go with patient.
What the fuck?
Okay, I got this patient.
Yeah, they're not gonna let you, they're not gonna let you
publish that.
They're gonna silence you.
Okay, eyedrops, maple syrup, herbs.
Maple syrup.
Eyedrop, herbs.
I was gonna say, I was like, Does that wall have eyes?
I was like, huh?
I don't remember walls blinking before.
That's new.
Alright, you already got that.
Oh, wait.
Wash your hands?
By the way, they said don't wash your hands.
God damn it.
They changed the rules.
Don't you hate it when...
Don't you hate it when the board...
just fucking change the rules like you on that.
All right.
Go get treated.
All right, last two patients, guys.
Does anyone know how many rounds this game has?
Oh, all right.
Somebody clean the poop.
Had a little accident.
What?
Oh, okay.
I was like, what was that?
Oh my god, there are everywhere it's endless i meant the how
about the lore though when this like is you can't it can't
be endless if it's like there's a limited amount of lore
okay green pink red oh i didn't see the first color guys
well what's the first color i know because it's always four
i didn't see the first one i saw green pink red was it red
red Green, pink, red.
There we go.
Alright, we got it.
Oh, my god, it's so fast now.
And cough syrup.
Luckily, it's right next to me.
I got through most of the lore?
When does it end?
Ooh, we treated 50 patients.
Nice.
Oh my god, Zap!
Oh!
Oh yeah, you know, that guy.
Yeah, get that guy out of here.
Is that money?
I'll grab that.
Yeah, get through all the people.
I don't even know we had all the people yet.
Alright.
Oh, yeah, shoot that guy.
Yeah, you...
We know you're an anomaly because you're looking at the
camera.
Everyone knows no one will look at the...
Everyone knows it's weird if you look at the security camera
directly.
I got his...
I printed his name tag out.
Alright, are you real?
Yeah, he's real.
Alright.
A fire started in room one.
Are we allowed back in the office?
With the doctor?
Doctor!
Did you finish your paperwork?
Yes, I'm listening.
Am I doing a good job?
Can I get promotion?
Guys, I don't think I'm getting the promotion.
Guys, I don't think I'm getting...
Oh, oh, she's...
Oh, my God, you suck up.
You little teacher's pet.
That's right.
I see you.
I fucking see you.
Oh, yeah, you're gonna give him...
Yeah, that's right.
That's right!
Try to suck up to the doctor for promotion...
I'm the head nurse!
Bitch.
Alright.
Okay.
They seem to be...
Oh.
They seem to be real.
Okay, yep.
They're just tired.
That's right.
I'm still the head nurse.
I have the head nurse skin.
Still me.
Okay.
Two more patients to check in.
Anyone brown nose?
Oh, shit.
Okay, we gotta fix these cameras.
I don't know if they're...
Oh, were they not real?
Why did we close the door?
Hey, somebody... Oh.
There's two.
Oh.
Alright, I'm going to make sure to delete that camera
footage for later.
I'm going to...
I'm going to make sure there's no proof that any shots
were...
Any gunshots happened at this hospital?
If you delete the proof, that means there's less paperwork.
Guys, think about that.
Less paperwork to do.
Oh my, I keep thinking that's an anomaly.
Wait, what?
I said that was the last patient.
There's one more patient left?
Oh, yeah, we gotta kill him.
Come on.
There we go.
What gunshots?
Yeah, what gunshots?
Oh, here you go.
Here's your mape.
There you go.
Here's your maple syrup.
All right, go back to Canada.
How nice of him.
Wait in line like everybody else in Canada for treatment.
Wait five to six months.
You think you get fast-tracked because you're in America
right now?
He was just hungry.
All right.
left medicine cough syrup
oh my god we're don't worry i believe in my team i thought
we checked in the last but how is there still more patients
it said zero patients okay now treat remaining patients okay
there we go all right i'll get the last one over here
Oh my god.
I need coffee.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Everything's fine.
Car have syrup.
Maple syrup.
I don't know if it was her, but I don't remember.
I'm still, I have PTSD right now.
I, I have Pete.
Oh my God.
Just a little PTSD.
Nothing to worry about.
Oh, yay.
Employee of the month.
When do we get new lore?
Oh, wait, Liz is back.
Hey, Liz.
What's Liz?
What is this doing here?
I almost got sent back to Canada.
They need more doctors, Doki.
We need you.
What, Liz?
They published your story and you're still alive?
That's right, it's me.
Here.
I brought you a copy.
Oh, nice.
Where is it?
oh it's right here the animal hospital prepares to celebrate
what the 30th anniversary next month the hospital is founded
by john a anomaly in hopes of finding cures for all animal
diseases by furthering his research on genes currently
projects being directed by renowned researcher dr everett l
harlow it's a conspiracy local flop but takes interesting
pictures of patients at animal hospital authorities are
confused about what everyone thing means but they are sure
she will have a bright future pursuing photography yeah I
mean that's not too bad I have to run picture unless they're
always busy goodbye friend yay it's gonna do well in
photography guys I might need another another bottle of
coffee all right let's see is there anything I can buy scan
what I'll grab more coins
oh wait it's still here what the fuck do I do with this
happen to be allergic to me happen to even thought
everything was fine at first something terrible happened and
the accident wait what happened I still visit this grave
every year leave flowers oh poor Ron
All right, let's see.
Guys, might need a little bit of help here.
Well, actually, they're all fine.
There never seem to be anomalies.
All right.
All right, go in.
Do we got all the lore, or is there more lore, guys?
Dragons, are there any more lore left?
Oh, no.
Someone's on fire.
Two goopers.
Alright.
Grabbing the map.
Oh, you got this?
Alright, you got it.
I'll fix the camera.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait.
No, you got it.
Some lore is roadblocked.
But do we have all the lore that we can unlock, though?
These guys are fine.
Oh, he fainted.
If there's still...
I actually don't know if there's still... Is there?
didn't even make it to the reception
it's like nope nope not on it can't even touch the window
all right oh my god someone get this fucking news oh my god
now you made me use my gun you made me use my gun liz oh yes
flowers he's here to visit
I'm surprised we haven't oh my god I kept okay there we go
I know there's one where you can get them to break the
window we haven't got the anomaly yet for that oh my god
they're all fainting all right I got this don't worry I went
to the gym for these just for this moment don't worry how
princess Gary you back there I bet I bet you're not sick.
I bet you fainted on purpose.
Oh, and you gooped on the floor?
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna scan this and someone else will cure you.
I did my job.
Alright, someone else cure patient.
I'm patient in room 5.
Someone else handle that in room 5.
What the fuck?
Wait, you can be up here now?
Oh, yo, you're so fucked up right now.
Alright, Did anyone get patient in room five?
It's a Roblox.
I know, it doesn't seem like it.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
It was emergency time.
I'm going for a shot.
Critical.
That guy looks like...
That you're not coming in.
Get out.
You're not coming to this hospital.
He didn't even make it.
I was like, no, no, no.
You're not.
You're not coming here.
Alright.
Surgery time.
Vegan surgery.
White.
Bandage
Scalpel What That's not gonna stop me from oh
I will die for
Well, someone was gonna die for this I guess
Um It looked like someone died for it And I gave him weed
during the surgery.
No!
I'm alive!
We did it, guys!
My god!
So yeah, I had teddy bear for a job well done.
money turned around the whole room started okay that's so
cheap though that's so in the middle of surgery in the
middle of surgery looking suddenly there's a fire like what
the fuck
medicine med kit i got the med kit you got the rest Here you
get the rest.
Yeah, just typical hospital stuff.
Like what the fuck was I supposed to do?
He had spontaneous combustion.
Or we did it guys.
We're doing it.
You know, it just happens.
Just spontaneous combustion.
Don't you hate it when you're Your surgical table just
bursts in flames Right in the middle of surgery?
Alright, who started a ritual?
Alright, Tommy.
Let's get this fire.
Visiting hours is over.
Yeah, I don't even hate it when that happens.
Guys, I don't even know if you guys know.
if we like got all the interactions all right guys what if
we just oh my god we've been playing for three hours okay
this is actually this past his time so fast all right guys
oh my god he ate the chocolate oh bonus $100 you gotta be
ready for anything dokey clearly buy money
I don't recall guys guys I'm gonna to call it here.
I'll let you guys continue.
I didn't think I didn't realize it's been three out and a
cry.
I never stopped.
I wish you luck, interns.
Interns.
I wish you luck on this run.
Your head, I've been on a 340 hour shift.
I gotta go home.
This is why I can't be a doctor.
There's possess patience.
But what if it's only 22?
I I was just told it's endless.
There's no ending.
We would be here at shift 69 if I wanted to.
For real.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys.
The head nurse needs to take a break, guys.
We haven't gone home since the first shift.
But it's.
been really really fun i will say i think um i think it has
been really really fun though i have i have enjoyed uh been
enjoying the game but actually i want to buy it wait let's
see um where's my private server where is it this is my
server wait where's my private uh what does This looks like
you're disconnected.
No, I would not.
I want to see what can I afford.
What can I afford right now?
I'm going to be a secretary.
I'm going to be a...
Wait, I'm going to be a paramedic, psychologist, doctor.
Jesus Christ.
Wait, what are the skins again?
Oh, max inventory.
Oh, I can't afford anything.
$5 for a...
Oh, that's cute.
Cleanup nurse, nurse, assistant nurse.
Oh, I like this one.
This nurse is so cute.
I could be a secretary, but what are the skins?
That's just...
Oh, Auburn.
Oh, this game was designed by a furry.
You can just tell.
Yeah, I think, I want to, I wish I could afford the, I was
$20 away.
Um, I think this, let's get, this nurse is cute.
This one's cute too.
Ah, the cute ones are so expensive.
Because I don't want to do, oh my, the little kids are
talking right now.
In the background!
Oh, wait, I'll buy the secretary and see how expensive they
are.
Oh, of course.
Yeah, of course it's $500.
Of course it is.
I could be a detective secretary.
Ooh.
Of course it's $500.
What about the head nurse?
Where are the skins for the head nurse?
Okay, the head nurses are not as cute, though.
I was a surgeon.
No, none of the secret agent.
Oh, my God.
Wait, Rathu is an agent.
Ratthew was a secret agent this entire time
Yeah, but that was really fun I actually enjoyed I enjoyed
like It doesn't feel like a Roblox game at all too So like
whoever made the game Like the dev teams that made the game
did a really good job Because it does not feel like a Roblox
game And I really enjoyed it I enjoyed playing it and um, I
would, I don't know, I felt like I had unlocked majority of
the lore because there's no new stuff happening in the
shifts now.
So now I'm just like, I'm gonna call it here because I was
like, oh my god, I didn't realize I was like three hours.
I've been, I've been running the hospital for three hours
now.
Like, yeah, it was a really fun game.
Um, I actually did.
Um, okay.
I thought about whether or not to keep playing a restory on
stream or not, not to because i played a little bit off
stream and i got like filtered hard i got because then they
introduced walkmans and by god okay walkman repairs are so
frustrating there's so many parts to it and i got hard
filtered because i was like like re deconstructing a walkman
and it took me like five minutes to deconstruct and
reconstruct again and i was just was too complicated.
Yeah.
They introduced the Walkmans and I was like, too many parts.
There's too many parts.
Yeah, I got to that part.
And no, apparently there's like hacking too.
They're going to introduce it.
I was reading about it.
You're like, oh yeah, you unlock hacking into the game.
So there's like more comp like it gets more and more
complicated too.
But like, it was so many parts and i was just like oh my god
it was so frustrating like reconstructing and constructing
it back together so i was just like i don't i don't think
i'm gonna be i don't think i'll like stream it on stream
i'll just play a little bit off stream um oh i haven't even
seen the laptop yeah i actually got filtered out of it i was
just like oh i can't i can't keep doing it i I can't play it
anymore Yeah, it's starting to become less cozy Under that,
yes, I will be streaming tomorrow I still don't know why I'm
streaming tomorrow So I'm just, I just wrote in my schedule
Something I still haven't decided what I want to play So,
but I will be streaming it at I'll do I'll do 5pm Tomorrow
at, actually 6pm 6pm PSD I don't know what game I'll be
playing I just said, I just wrote something on my schedule
so um we'll find out tomorrow at 6 p.m p.sd hey guys i hope
you guys enjoyed the double streams today as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and run around
to get that blood flowing and if you sail for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye